طيب
خليني اتكلم اول شيء ريان انا ما سمعتك بس
خليني اتكلم عن ظاهره سوق المنهوبات اليوم
اصبح للمنهوبات سوق في السودان
نعم طب ريان ايضا موضوع اخر من السودان ما
زال طبعا الفنانون السودانيون يتفاعلون مع
الحرب بالكثير من العمل التطوعي اعطينا
تفاصيل اكثر
بالفعل يعني في لفت انسانيه بارعه كرس
يعني نجوم او بعض نجوم المجتمع السوداني
صفحات على منصات مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
التي يديرونها
والتي تتابع من قبل مئات يعني الالاف
وربما الملايين من الناس للحالات
الانسانيه وايضا حالات المفقودين والاسر
المتعففه والمحتاجه وبعض مشكلات النازحين
واللاجئين ويتفاعل بالتاكيد رواد موقع
التواصل الاجتماعي بالشيء ايجابي وبالدور
فاعل جدا مع هذه
الصفحات
طيب شكرا جزيلا للريان رغم
الخلل التقني ورغم الاوضاع وسوء الانترنت
ولكن ستكوني معنا ان شاء الله كل اسبوع
وهو دائما يا الرياض
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات